compte chaque marchand oui j'avoue que
votre livre moi m'a donné un autre
aspect du boxeur je reste sur le plan de
la boc semaines nous avions
effectivement l'impression que vous
étiez le pont paron que vous racontez
d'ailleurs que vous dénoncez mais il ya
dans ce livre un boxeur qui a beaucoup
de sentiments et qui en particulier un
sentiment de confraternité qu'on ne vous
connaissais pas
car les apparences c'est d'injurier vos
adversaires vous en avez fait un jeu où
les insulter avant vous avez insultés
liston à une certaine époque et ensuite
vous l'avez fait que foreman que vous
prêtez si j'ai bonne mère je vous cite
de [ __ ] de concèze de du conte etc
et puis soudain on décompte on découvre
dans votre libération
cette fraternité que vous avez pour
votre adversaire et vous nous dites dans
votre livre que foreman est le plus fort
de sa génération que frasier parmi les
plus grands boxeurs de tous les temps et
puis vous avouer qu effectivement vous
aimeriez être l'ami de radier boudry y
est même son ami native et il émane de
ce livre un autre un autre mohamed ali
est-ce que c'est voulu de nous donner
maintenant une autre image ou est-ce que
votre attitude lorsque vous insultez vos
adversaires est uniquement une attitude
publicitaire est ce que vous voulez
décourager vos adversaires ou
j'encourage et vous même tout d'abord
monsieur vous avez l'air d'être un homme
intelligent donc je vends du principe
que vous l'êtes et que vous sachez
reconnaître la vérité qu'en voulant
quand vous entendez
tandis que l'homme qui n'a pas
d'imagination a les pieds sur terre mais
ne peut pas s'envoler car il n'a pas
d'elle
l'homme qui a construit la tour eiffel
avait de l'imagination
je suis monté un tour eiffel aujourd'hui
et c'est presque incroyable de penser
que dans la nuit des temps pratiquement
à un homme a eu la clairvoyance et
l'imagination de construire quelque
chose d'aussi postienne arnos immense
les frères wright avait de l'imagination
ils ont construit le premier avion les
gens à un moment penser que le monde
était carey seulement christophe-colomb
avez de l'imagination donc à boxer dans
la gloire que j'ai actuellement donc un
boxeur de gagne autant d'argent que moi
pourquoi parce qu'ils n'ont pas la même
imagination et non pas dans
l'imagination
non j'étais en train de bourrer le crâne
des gens lorsque j'essaie de leur faire
croire faire croire aux gens que j'étais
un [ __ ] vous avez vous être vu et les
revenus de la lutte la lutte américaine
où les catcheurs en fait on a vraiment
l'impression que ils vont ce centre
voilà voilà une espèce de mimiques
calacanis ses livres mais celui qui fait
ça bien c'est pas comme on interprète de
demandes
l'orateur ce genre de bruit c'est pas
très bien non plus vite
d voilà voilà une espèce de l'image vous
voyez l'image de ce que le photographe
hu et ses salles photographe c'est ça le
promoteur qui a une immense qu'est une
grande douche parce que le promoteur lui
à cent mille places qui doit remplir
cent mille places dans le stade
lorsque alors il est peut-être pas
mauvais comme avait dali commença à
faire le zouave un petit peu en faisant
semble de haïr sur l'adversaire réciter
quelques balles ça c'est de la promotion
non le vrai moi c'est ce que vous avez
vous précisément discerner dans ce livre
karas ajustements ne peut pas être
leurré seulement celui qui n'est pas ça
je ne peux pas leur et celui qu'il est
moi j'ai simplement fait les masses
est ce que vous croyez tout de même que
c'est vraiment nécessaire à notre image
de marque de faire le faire le fanfaron
de faire le clown et sous pensez vous ne
seriez pas ensemble et membres en ont
pesé dans la boxe si vous étiez calme
l'homme sens et qu'il ya donc ce livre
est l'homme sensible
là vous avez des pages admirables dans
ce n'est vous avez des braches d'une
très grande sensibilité
nous on ne reprenait pas du tout le flou
que vous êtes content vous voulez jouer
qu'une mère est intéressant à propos de
cette fanfaronnade 7 jacques tanguay
injure c'est que même et à leeds à un
moment donné j'ai observé ça m'a touché
ce que tout le monde ignore c'est
qu'avant de monter sur le ring je meurs
de peur que cela ne serait pas une
manière d'exorciser la peur et de la
vraie question que je posais tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs encouragé
l'adversaire je suis à répondre à la
question le sait gêne les blancs plus
que les noirs parce que pour les noirs
je peux assurer que cela donne le
sentiment de confiance parce que
n'oubliez pas que nous sommes nous
sommes les inférieur et eux sont fiers
de devoir précisément à de leurs frères
en train de dire aux gens ce qu'il a à
leur dire parce que bon à paris 1
l'angleterre en amérique par tous les
noirs ont l'impression d'être traités
comme des animaux
alors c'est une revanche pour eux quand
ils me voient
c'est une inspiration pour eux vous vous
vous n'aimez pas beaucoup ce genre de
fanfaronnade pas ce que vous dites
qu'elle est ce noir qu'elle se loi ouvre
sa grande gueule
non nous ne nous ne lui avons jamais
appuyé à se comporter de la sorte nous
nous avons fait des esclaves des gens
comme ça nous n'avons jamais appris à
ces gens-là d'être fiers non parce que
le mollet tous les modèles tous les
mannequins sont des femmes blanches on
le sait bien et jésus-christ tout le
monde tout le monde
un plan tout était blanc alors quel est
ce noir qui subitement se permettent
d'ouvrir sa grande gueule pour dire
qu'il est le plus grand alors ça ça vous
gêne